j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour vous le savez des bas de société
notre objectif c'est de prendre du recul
de vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des des mutations de la
société française à quelques jours de la
fin du tirage au sort des citoyens qui
vont participer à la Convention sur la
fin de vie on va se demander s'il faut
modifier la loi Claes Leonetti celle qui
s'applique aujourd'hui comme dans ce
centre de soins palliatifs ou s'est
rendus Pierre-Henri holderborn
cette infirmière de l'équipe mobile des
soins palliatifs de Dinant accompagnés
pendant de nombreux mois un homme d'une
soixantaine d'années atteint de la
maladie de Charcot
Laetitia se rend au domicile de l'épouse
qui a bien voulu témoigner anonymement
bonjour vous donc par les appels du coup
vous aviez vraiment un soutien une
écoute et c'est vrai que ça fait du bien
de pouvoir compter sur quelqu'un de
pouvoir discuter on est perdu on sait
que en plus c'est une maladie on sait
que
il y a rien je n'aurais jamais voulu moi
avoir y venir souffrir jamais des
périodes difficiles où l'euthanasie a
parfois traversé l'esprit de cette femme
est-ce qu'il a pu exprimer d'être dans
cette demande il l'a dit pas
d'acharnement il a dit pas d'acharnement
il a pas dit je veux mourir ou je
demande à mourir non jamais j'allais pas
rentrer dans le sujet de de sa fin de
vie parce que il était tellement
battant
un soutien et être à l'écoute du patient
et des familles mais aussi
l'accompagnement à la réflexion de prise
de décision parfois complexe une
méconnaissance du métier aux yeux du
grand public alors qu'une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie va
prochainement débuter
ça veut dire qu'il y a plus de
traitement
possible pour guérir la pathologie mais
on fait un accompagnement de vie on
n'est pas là juste pour faire des soins
techniques on n'est pas là juste pour
faire une injection on n'est pas l'âge
pour faire une toilette on est là pour
être bienveillant pour faire notre
maximum pour le patient confronter à la
fin de vie quotidiennement ils ont une
vision différente des attentes de la
société sur l'ouverture de la damourir
selon un sondage
78% des Français souhaitent un
changement de la loi en faveur de la
légalisation de l'euthanasie et du
suicide médicalement assisté au regard
de tous les patients a eu des gens qui
étaient pour avoir une euthanasie
et qui sont arrivés chez nous en soins
palliatifs et bien la soif de vivre a
été quand la plus forte quoi donc c'est
pour ça c'est très compliqué alors
d'aujourd'hui moi je
sais que je pourrai pas pousser une
seringue pour dire non le soin est-ce
que c'est jusqu'à donner la mort c'est
une vraie question ça implique aussi des
choix de société avec des répercussions
qui sont énormes c'est vraiment
difficile de répondre à cette question
moi à titre personnel je ne pense pas je
pourrais répondre à une demande de
thanazi en tout cas en tout cas pas
quelque chose qui se ferait seul face au
patients dans le bureau de l'équipe
mobile des soins palliatifs
on va faire la première petite à
domicile pour faire la connaissance voir
le projet de vie on s'inquiète tout de
même du débat même s'il reste utile pour
l'un des médecins après je crains qu'on
précipite un peu les choses parce que
depuis 20 ans on n'a pas pu
pratiquer des soins palliatifs au niveau
où on avait envisagé on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gens il y a
probablement un tiers de la population
qui a pas accès du tout à des structures
de soins palliatifs mais cette
convention citoyenne masque des
problèmes bien plus profonds cette
discussion ne nous apparaît pas par
prioritaire en tout cas et qu'elle
apparaît à un moment où il y aurait bien
d'autres choses à faire comme revoir le
système de financement des hôpitaux ben
ça on en parle plus c'est vrai que c'est
une loi qui va arriver qui va être
extrêmement clivante sur le plan des
prises de position et qui risque
d'esquiver les vrais problèmes de
l'hôpital qui est en vrai crise
aujourd'hui il y a une composante
économique à notre sens à mon sens en
tout cas dans la loi sur l'euthanasie le
13 septembre dernier le Conseil
consultatif nationale d'éthique a pour
la première fois rendu un avis favorable
à l'ouverture de la dame mourir une fois
terminée la convention citoyenne
remettra ses conclusions au gouvernement
je vous présente mes invités Florence la
Sarrade bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
médecin vous êtes sénatrice salaire de
giron des secrétaire de la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat Valérie
depad bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
maître de conférence en droit privé
spécialisé en biomédecine et membre de
la mission Sika sur la fin de vie Denis
label bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes médecin vous êtes qu'aux
président de l'association le choix
citoyen pour une mort choisie et votre
livre le médecin la liberté et la mort
pour le droit de choisir sa fin de vie
livre publiée chez plomb et Laetitia
cruppa éditoris politique est resté à
mes côtés je vais rappeler pour
commencer ce débat pour ouvrir ce débat
ce que dit la loi Claes Leonetti elle
prévoit la possibilité de recourir à la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès pour les personnes malades dont le
pronostic vital est engagé à court terme
avec arrêt de tous les traitements
Florence lasarade est-ce que cette loi
elle est adaptée à la situation est-ce
qu'il faut la changer je pense que si
elle est bien ok elle est adaptée à
pratiquement tous les cas je pense que
la maladie Charcot par contre pose
peut-être question enfin mais est-ce
qu'on doit mettre une exception dans une
loi j'en sais rien le problème c'est que
l'accompagnement en particulier à
domicile se fait très mal
et vraiment tous les passions n'ont pas
la chance de pouvoir organiser un
parcours complet
on sait pas quel sera l'heure de la mort
mais on en a quand même une petite idée
et il manque vraiment de
d'accompagnement on fait la loi classe
léonity n'est pas suffisamment appliqué
à mon avis ça pose la question n'y
viendra dans ce débat sur l'accès aux
soins palliatifs en France qui est
évidemment une vraie dimension de de
difficulté et du débat Valérie de pas de
quand on parle de sédation profonde et
continue ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que pour des raisons enfin dans un but
de confort lorsque la personne est
proche du décès le Conseil d'État estime
cette période de quelques heures à
quelques jours on endort la personne on
l'endort de façon à ce qu'elle ne se
réveille pas jusqu'au décès donc comme
on est très près du décès elle va
décéder de sa maladie ce qui serait pas
possible bien sûr à moyen terme on
pourrait pas utiliser cette technique
donc c'est un temps où la personne est
endormie ou les beaucoup de médecins je
peux pas parler en plus je suis pas
médecin mais je travaille avec des
médecins réanimateurs qui sont très
sceptiques vis-à-vis de cette période de
sommeil qui est une période pendant
laquelle on ne sait pas exactement c'est
ce qu'ils disent ce qui se passe pour le
patients ou pas on sait pas on ne sait
pas de toute façon et cette période est
très dure à vivre pour les proches ça
c'est l'expérience qu'il montre donc
voilà je pense que cette sédation
profonde et continue qui a enfin dont on
comprend le sens elle permet de pas
transgresser l'interdiction de porter
atteinte à la vie et le en Hippocrate
c'est une mesure de confort mais
l'application montre en tout cas montrer
au médecin qu'il reste des zones tombent
difficilement acceptables
quelque chose ça peut être très long
quand on voit le corps souffrir voilà
Lambert je crois que ça a été 9 jours 9
jours
Denis labelde 2007 je crois vous aviez
lancé un manifeste de 2000 soignants
reconnaissants avoir pratiqué le tanasie
à propos de de la loi klessonetti et de
cette sédation profonde vous dites que
ce sont les conditions d'application qui
sont trop restrictives expliquez-nous
pourquoi
l'intitulé de cette loi est positif
c'est la version profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès on a l'impression
d'entrer dans un projet de société
intéressant ça le problème c'est que peu
de gens lisent l'application de cette
loi qui a été écrite par la Haute
Autorité de santé sous l'impulsion c'est
marqué de c'était française de soins
palliatifs or l'application pour nous
pose d'énormes problèmes en ce sens à la
fois sur le des indications c'est à dire
qu'il faut vraiment être un stade très
mortem avoir des douleurs incontrôlables
alors là vraiment je trouve que sur le
plan humain il y a un vrai problème et
puis ça élimine un certain nombre
d'indications ce qui a été dit toutes
les maladies neurodégénératives et puis
il y a un problème méthodologique
profond qui nous pose un problème
éthique à nombre de médecins
1 on nous demande de déshydrater les
malades soit disons que ça accélère mais
c'est faux si on veut accélérer il
suffit d'augmenter les doses de sédatif
et de morphinique c'est une évidence et
la deuxième chose c'est que la sédation
telle qu'elle est proposée est
progressive si bien que vous aboutissez
à une agonie prolongée pour moi inutile
mon frère est mort en 2021
hémorragie cérébrale un mois d'agonie un
mois d'agonie faut savoir ce que ça
représente pour le patient qui gêne ce
que vous disiez tout à fait exact on ne
sait pas ce qui se passe et pour les
familles c'est quelque chose de terrible
et pour le personnel soignant donc on
est devant une loi avec un texte enfin
je veux dire une intitulé positif et une
application qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
acceptable est-ce qu'il faut dresser une
liste précise lasarade de vous avez déjà
répondu de des maladies pour lesquelles
les passions pourraient demander le
tadésie
non c'est ce que je disais d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
donner une indication sur une maladie
donnée non mais
moi j'étais interpellé en post mortem
j'ai reçu un courrier
d'une personne qui a une maladie de
Charcot et qui ne me demandait de faire
quelque chose par contre j'ai
personnellement accompagné mon mari moi
jusqu'à la fin et et
j'ai enfin je me serais pas venu à
l'idée que quelqu'un vienne pousser la
seringue et
il m'a demandé ça fait deux jours que je
demande qu'on m'aide à mourir et je lui
dis bah enfin on parlait assez
naturellement ça va pas tarder alors il
me dit bon ah bon voilà et et
c'est aucun accompagnement mais j'avais
beaucoup de médecins enfin si un
accompagnement familial mais c'est vrai
que au point de vue au point de vue
structure de soins palliatifs comme on
n'était pas sur notre lieu de résidence
mais sur notre lieu de vacances ça c'est
pas fait
il a fallu se débrouiller quand même
mais
il y a eu cet échange j'ai demandé qu'on
m'aide à mourir ça devient pas et puis
en même temps ça faisait quand même des
mois qui s'accrochaient à la vie etc
qu'il avait un instinct de survie
terrible et spontanément ça va pas
tarder et le fait de dire ça ça
désamorçait ce son angoisse parce que il
y a la souffrance physique mais il y a
aussi l'angoisse de la mort chez le
patient et je crois que ça c'est quand
un patient c'est pas un objet il faut
vraiment mesurer cette cette souffrance
psychologique je pense à l'hôpital non
moi j'ai pas et puis on n'a pas
forcément envie d'aller à l'hôpital
aller à l'hôpital moi ce que ce qu'on
entend ce que je me suis entendu dire
parce que c'est vrai on s'est posé la
question qu'est-ce repart à l'hôpital
en même temps il y a des protocoles avec
des pochons de morphine enfin moi on
aurait pu l'organiser on dit ah mais
faut l'hospitaliser parce que ce que
vous faites est dangereux bon vous voyez
c'est ça va il y a quand même aussi un
décalage parfois entre ce qu'on entend
et la vraie vie je repose pardon de
reprendre la main mais parce que vous
avez réagiaire pourquoi ce serait
dangereux pour vous c'est pas dangereux
mon avis c'est mal adapté tout
simplement parce que chaque situation
est particulière et singulière et une
liste finalement semble dire toutes les
personnes qui ont cette maladie alors
déjà c'est terrible psychologiquement
lorsqu'on va annoncer à ces personnes
quels sont sur la liste entre guillemets
et puis avec la même maladie les choses
les personnes vont vivre tout à fait
différemment donc Nice non vous savez le
même problème c'est poser un assistance
médicale à la procréation pour les tests
prénataux mon anciennement des pour
pouvoir réaliser
poser une intervention médicale de
grossesse est-ce qu'il fallait dresser
une liste des maladies graves et on l'a
pas fait parce que les parents voilà
c'est très singulier
une réaction
tout de suite celle de Virginie fossé
Diaz et les chefs de service en soins
palliatifs à l'hôpital Bretonneau à
Paris voici ce qu'elle nous dit il y a
pas de demande d'euthanasie dans notre
unité il y a quelques fois des demandes
de citations profondes et continue la
sédation profonde et continue nous en
pratiquons de temps en temps mais ça
répond à un cadre c'est dans le cadre de
symptômes non contrôlés malgré les
toutes les thérapeutiques
ce n'est pas une décision isolée c'est
une décision collégiale avec le patient
ou sa personne de confiance et en équipe
alors là c'est un témoignage sur un
service à l'hôpital Bretonneux dit il y
a peu de demandes Denis label est-ce
qu'on peut évaluer ça parce que la
question qui vient avec c'est est-ce
qu'il faut changer la loi s'il y a peu
de demandes vous voyez ce que je veux
dire si vous voulez l'important c'est
d'écouter les malades et moi qui suis
dans le service hospitalier j'écoutais
les patients et les demandes sont
extrêmement variables vous avez des gens
à qui on dit vous allez partir en soins
palliatifs ils disent bon d'accord bon
on sait jamais de par plaisir dans un
cadre où les gens meurent il y a des
gens qui vous disent ben écoutez moi non
moi je préférerais rester avec vous là
vous êtes une équipe sympathique je
préfère rester dans votre hôpital je
connais les infirmières je connais
médecin puis le doute qui vous disent
docteur vous ne comprenez pas j'ai envie
de partir je n'ai pas envie d'être
accompagné j'ai envie de partir ce n'est
pas la majorité mais il existe c'est
pourcentage et je crois qu'une loi
aurait trois intérêts le premier c'est
en effet de répondre à ce pourcentage
peut-être faible mais qui existe de
patients qu'ils demandent l'aide
d'activité va mourir la deuxième c'est
que ça modifierait considérablement la
pratique des soins palliatifs et de la
sédation profondé continue c'est à dire
qu'en Belgique il n'y a pas de frontière
entre les soit palliatifs et l'aide
activa mourir en France il y a une
frontière rigide et la troisième chose
c'est que cette loi réduirait l'angoisse
des gens moi je suis des patients un
médecin particulier qui avait un cancer
du pancréas qui fait extrêmement
angoisser
il me dit est-ce que vous m'aiderait
à partir à partir je dis oui
et à ce moment là il s'est remis à vivre
il est parti voyage
complètement soulagé
je déciderai du moment où ça va se
terminer donc je peux je peux vivre
tranquillement et il a vécu pendant deux
ans avec un cancer de banque rassemblant
n'est pas je me souviens de demander
c'était un diagnostics
sont morts sans problème sans moi il est
mort brutalement et donc pendant deux
ans cet homme a vécu sans angoisse
uniquement parce qu'il avait cette
possibilité
et en Belgique 80% des gens
souhaitent maintenir la loi uniquement
pour cette raison là de désengers alors
qu'il y a seulement 2,5% des gens qui
demandent l'euthanasie je reviens à bon
cette sédation profonde et continue je
connaissais comment la décision était le
prix c'est collégiale qui décide
vraiment il y a la famille il y a le
patient il y a le médecin enfin comment
soit le patient la demande parce qu'il
décide d'arrêter les traitements et
qu'on sait et il sait que cet arrêt va
entraîner souffrances soit c'est le
médecin qui le décide parce que la
personne en état de s'exprimer mais
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt le médecin
qui a la main quand même malgré tout
parce que c'est lui qui qui maîtrise les
données médicales par définition vous
voyez ce que je veux dire quand la
personne n'est pas capable de quand elle
est capable de s'exprimer c'est elle qui
décide le médecin va la suivre en
principe je pense ou contrôle de médecin
en principe vous êtes un principe
alors vous nous expliquer le principe
quand elle n'est pas consciente là le
médecin à la suite d'une procédure
collégiale c'est-à-dire il va avoir des
avis il va discuter avec l'équipe
soignante et d'autres et à membre
extérieur là c'est lui qui va prendre la
décision d'endormir la personne donc
d'arrêter les traitements c'est la même
décision on arrête on endort par confort
pourquoi vous êtes dubitatif parce que
c'est quand on est quand on est malade à
ce point-là c'est peut-être difficile de
garder du discernement je sais pas je
sais vraiment parce que les gens le
demandent l'écrivent dans leur directive
anticipées et en face on trouve toujours
des arguments pour dire c'est pas encore
le moment
vous avez des douleurs mais on peut
encore les contrôler et c'est pas au
médecin de décider si les douleurs sont
incontrôlables ces tomada de dire je ne
m'en peux plus et c'est ça qui est
important c'est actuellement on a une
loi médicale et comme disent les Belges
nous on a une loi de citoyens c'est
toute la différence
cette histoire de de
directive anticipée je recherchais c'est
pas si simple parce que on peut on peut
les les écrire et être des conseils
en novembre 2022 il y a quelques jours
il y a pas longtemps parce qu'une
personne dans ses directives avait écrit
qu'elle voulait être maintenue en vie
quelle que soit son état c'est-à-dire
voilà quel que soit son état elle
voulait maintenir vite tant que c'était
possible
en principe les directives anticipés
s'imposent au médecin donc il les suit
il discute pas simplement il y a deux
exceptions dont une et l'urgence elle
pose pas de problème elle est logique et
l'autre
réside dans des directives qui seraient
manifestement inapproprié qui laisse
donc au médecin une marge de décision là
la personne était dans le coma en face
c'est moi j'ai lu la décision on en
parlait il semblait qu'elle était en
coma voir en coma dépassé
le médecin a voulu arrêter les soins et
il est proche de la personne on saisit
la justice parce qu'il y a utilisé cette
cette exception donc la question qui se
pose et qu'est-ce qu'une directive ou
qu'est-ce que sont des directives
manifestement inappropriés mais
heureusement que cette exception existe
on voit vraiment toute la complexité de
la prise de de décision je voudrais
qu'on parle des soins palliatifs parce
que c'est quand même on l'évoque en
permanence mais il y a quelques chiffres
moi je vous l'avoue qui m'ont frappé
pour ne pas dire choqué la question de
l'accès réel aux soins palliatifs en
France dans un département français sur
quatre on va voir les chiffres dans un
département français sur quatre il n'y a
tout simplement pas d'unité spécialisée
et concrètement selon la société
française d'accompagnement et de soins
palliatifs 70% des patients qui en ont
besoin n'ont pas accès n'ont pas accès à
ces points elle est peut-être là
l'urgence Florence la même temps
l'hôpital français est en crise donc les
soins palliatifs aussi c'est peut-être
une évidence mais en particulier idéal
serait quand même si c'est possible de
de mourir à domicile si on peut si la
famille si la famille est d'accord c'est
ce que souhaite quand même
lors du vieillissement aussi le
fait de mourir chez soi ça je pense que
ça peut aussi un petit peu adoucir les
choses mais est-ce que ça veut dire
parce que le système est insuffisant ou
est-ce que il faut il faut modifier la
façon d'accompagner je pense qu'il y a
encore une marge de progrès très
importante sur la façon d'accompagner et
comme de toute façon
là il y a plus d'erreurs médicales de ça
faisait plus il y a plus de temps que le
malade on peut le sauver qu'il y a une
histoire de survie c'est vrai que là la
responsabilité du soignant et tout
entière une fois qu'on sait que l'issue
est fatal et imminente moi il me semble
qu'on peut on peut mettre là quand même
le paquet pour pour accompagner
correctement mais également avec des
paramédicaux c'est pas forcément
c'est on parle beaucoup de l'infirmière
je pense qu'il y a aussi
nécessité de de d'ailleurs que les
étudiants en études médicales ou
l'infirmière soit initié soit palliatif
à la fin de vie et ça ça manque
cruellement puis la fin de vie ça peut
être très tôt dans la vie moi j'étais
pédiatre de réanimation et je peux vous
assurer que c'était pas toujours
facile de prendre des décisions
maintenant on fait vraiment des soins
palliatifs même en salle de naissance
au nouveau ça peut être déjà
très il y a des moments dans la ville
les ans il peut y avoir des enfants
atteints de de maladies cancéreuses
incurable enfin ça se pose à n'importe
quel moment de la vie alors on va
je pense qu'il y a deux problèmes pour
les radiatif il y a un problème
quantitatif et un problème qualitatif
problème quantitatif c'est exact et il
n'y a pas assez de structure de soins
palliatifs mais comme vous l'a dit on
est en pleine crise
hospitalière on a supprimé 40 % des
listes hospitalisation on est en pleine
crise médicale on a supprimé 25% des
médecins généralistes et des médecins
spécialistes ou allez-vous c'est pas une
problème d'argent ou allez-vous trouver
et la technique Lenny et les hommes et
les infirmières donc ça sa première
problème quantitatif il y a problème
qualitatif tout de même c'est que les
soins les soins palliatifs ça doit
répondre un éventail de possibilité
c'est pas seulement des secteurs des
ghettos de gens qui sont en train de
nourrir ce que vous dites nous sommes
tout à fait exact c'est à dire qu'il
faut que les malades puissent mourir à
domicile dans des conditions humaines
satisfaisantes or actuellement
il y a une philosophie au niveau des
soins palliatifs qui est une très
restrictif c'est à dire
à dire qu'il faut entrer dans un schéma
je dirais qu'avec une notion religieuse
des soins palliatifs puisque il le cache
pas je veux dire il y a une orientation
qui ne correspond pas à la au désir de
tout le monde
la société française de soins palliatifs
une orientation c'est clair
c'est à dire que en fait son programme
est tout à fait calqué sur des
programmes religieux donc c'est à dire
c'est quoi le c'est Dieu qui a le
pouvoir de vie mort sur les humains
c'est-à-dire que vous avez deux choses
qui sont vous avez la vie coûte que
coûte et soutenu par tous les mouvements
monothéistes et puis de l'autre côté
vous avez la lutte contre la souffrance
en médecine c'est pas seulement les
religions monotistes c'est humain
c'est contradictoire quoi vraiment de la
vie ça peut devenir contradictoire au
nombre de cas on arrive à répondre aux
deux
vous guérissez quelqu'un à la fois vous
supprimez la souffrance et vous lui
donnez la vie mais il y a un moment où
la maladie prend le dessus et c'est là
où le choix doit se poser c'est à dire
que le citoyen est confronté à deux
choses est-ce que je préfère la vie
coûte que coûte ou la lutte contre la
souffrance et ça dépend je dirais des
orientations philosophiques et
religieuses de chacun c'est
insupportable d'être infantile lié
finalement c'est insupportable que
quelqu'un d'autre décide pour vous alors
la religion peut aussi être un support
dans ces moments je vous propose
d'entendre tout de suite
Monseigneur Mathieu rouget qui est
évêque de Nanterre ancien de Monnier des
parlementaires et qui réagissaient il y
a quelques jours voilà ce débat sur la
loi Clayes Leonetti euthanasie ou pas
nous sommes là pour choisir la vie cette
question l'euthanasie revient
régulièrement dans le dans le débat
c'est une question très sensible sur
lequel il faut pas être caricatural on
peut pas parler de ce sujet avec des
formules à l'emporte-pièce mais en même
temps rien n'est plus important
qu'aujourd'hui accompagner
les personnes en fin de vie ou dans des
situations de handicap handicap ou de
maladies chroniques très lourdes pour
qu'elles puissent vivre le mieux
possible parce que la l'honneur de notre
société c'est de permettre à chacun
d'être accompagné dans sa vie et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une époque
qui a beaucoup de mal avec la fragilité
nous sommes aussi dans une époque où on
voudrait faire comme si la mort pouvait
être en quelque sorte évacuée nous
croyons que la mort doit être assumée et
accompagné Florence la Sarrade dans une
République laïque comme la nôtre est-ce
qu'il faut qu'elle place il faut donner
aux arguments de la religion catholique
ou d'ailleurs des autres religions
monothéistes moi je pense que la
religion c'est une affaire très
personnelle
je vois pas en quoi là la religion
s'immis dans la fin de vie et dans
l'ensemble il me semble pas que les
Français soient tellement favorables que
ça soit la religion qui décide chaque
chaque expérience c'est vraiment
unique et personnel et moi ce qui me
même dans les dans les rédactions
anticipées de
volonté de de
directives anticipées
ce qui me gêne c'est que quand on
connaît pas malade et qu'on n'est pas
confronté à la maladie on peut vivre
sans
probablement sans religion enfin
le la c'est la mort qui a créé les
religions on fait c'est la peur de la
mort qui a quand même aussi créé les
religions je pense pas qu'on puisse
évacuer ça totalement mais je pense ce
sont des décisions tellement
individuelles parfois familiale que
c'est
je crois pas que que les Français se
laissent diriger par leur religion en
matière de de directive anticipée ou de
de soins palliatifs
c'est un c'est un support une aide à un
moment donné ça ça permet de mieux
passer je vais reprendre la pour pour
parler de la convention citoyenne
puisque si on évoque ce sujet de la fin
de vie dans le sens publique c'est parce
que dans quelques jours voilà on aura
fini de tirer au sort les citoyens qui
vont participer Jérémy isman vous pouvez
nous nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Jérémy alors en quoi consiste
cette convention citoyenne sur la femme
bien c'était une volonté du Président de
la République qui a confié son
organisation au Conseil économique
social et environnemental avec un
fonctionnement finalement assez
semblable à celui de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat concrètement
cette convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie réunit 150 personnes tirées au sort
depuis fin octobre jusqu'à début
décembre donc dans quelques jours qui
devront discuter de cette question
précise le cadre d'accompagnement de fin
de vie est-il adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées ou d'éventuelles
changements devraient-ils être introduit
des citoyens indemnisés et sélectionnés
selon plusieurs critères le genre l'âge
le lieu de résidence rurale ou urbain la
région d'origine le niveau de diplôme et
la catégorie socioprofessionnelle l'idée
étant d'obtenir un panel évidemment le
plus diversifié et représentatif
possible une mini-france qui n'exclut
personne ni les soignants ni les
militants selon les organisateurs et
quels seront les grandes étapes de cette
convention et bien premier rendez-vous
le 9 décembre à Paris et au total ce
seront 9 sessions qui auront lieu
jusqu'à mars des sessions organisées en
trois phases il y aura une phase
d'appropriation et de rencontres puis
une phase de délibération et enfin une
phase d'harmonisation et de restitution
des travaux des conclusions des travaux
qui seront présentés fin mars 2023 au
gouvernement pour aiguiller sa décision
de changer ou non la loi classes
Leonetti sur l'accompagnement médical de
fin de vie pour l'instant l'exécutif
c'est uniquement engagé à revenir vers
les citoyens et leur propositions mais
cette fois pas de promesses
d'applications sans filtre d'Emmanuel
Macron qui avait été très critiquée pour
ne pas avoir avoir tenu ses engagements
vis-à-vis de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat merci Jérémy Valérie
depatte je reviens vers vous sur cette
question de la convention citoyenne donc
on va avoir
des Français on l'a bien compris une
mini-france là qui va se retrouver à
devoir trancher ce dilemme qui est d'une
complexité absolue
mais quand même quoi moi
la démocratie c'est bien
donc je suis pour tout ce qui est
démocratique simplement elle est mini
mini la France là c'est 150 personnes
avec autant de catégories représentées
bon voilà
leurs conviction éventuellement
religieuses
avec leur vie sur le dos en quelque
sorte
dans ces sujets pour se débarrasser de
ce qui est sa conviction personnelle et
pouvoir intégrer des arguments et
entendre c'est impossible quand voilà je
crois qu'on est tous les trois d'accord
on travaille sur ce sujet depuis
longtemps bien souvent en tout cas en
droit en tout cas je vais parler pour
moi c'est assez facile d'habiller ces
convictions on trouve toujours une règle
qui va le permettre et c'est très
difficile de travailler autre enfin très
difficile en tout cas ça demande de
l'expérience donc je suis un tout petit
peu sceptique voilà un tout petit peu
sceptique Florence la salade à la fin de
ce processus c'est le le Parlement et le
Sénat qui qui reprendront la main quoi
de toute façon il faut le rappeler c'est
déjà pas une mini-france et suffisamment
représentatif de la population moi je
m'agace de toutes ces conventions
citoyennes pour pour tous les enfin ça
fait - 5 ans que je suis parlementaire
on va de convention citoyenne en
convention citoyenne alors que au
Parlement on peut on peut et on doit
débattre de ce sujet et en commission on
est en approfondie les choses c'est un
peu de la comment dire je vais pas dire
que c'est démagogie mais ça répond alors
c'est un autre débat je vais pas
l'ouvrir mais ça répond aussi à une
désaffection des des Français pour la
politique les élections le manque de
participation enfin bref c'est aussi
pour ça que les conventions citoyennes
sont que tout le monde très bien mais
bon
nous on a quand même peut-être un peu
plus de de cartes en main et pour pour
réfléchir et et bon on sait que les
débats au Parlement sont quand même
assez riche au Sénat en particulier et
on est ici pour le pour les pour les
relayer le plus souvent possible
Laetitia c'était une promesse forte de
la campagne présidentielle d'Emmanuel
Macron cette convention citoyenne et là
on a le sentiment qui temporise un peu
en fait on est face à un paradoxe parce
que il a porté un cette réforme et de la
répéter ses équipes aussi on fait savoir
aux journalistes que ce serait le grand
chantier de son dernier quinquennat
puisque il ne se représentera pas et
puis lui-même a raviver la flamme
rappelez-vous quand il a décoré Line
Renaud de la Légion d'honneur en
glissant un mot en glissant ce mot que
tout le monde finalement a entendu on le
fera c'est le moment bah oui c'est le
moment et puis cet automne freinage
rétropédalage temporisation éloignement
de la figure présidentielle qui selon
son entourage ne veut pas incarner le
débat d'ailleurs ces équipes ont reçu
pour consigne de ne pas dire
euthanasie il ne faut pas prononcer ce
mot mais fin de vie parce que ça inclut
on l'a dit il a tout à l'heure les soins
palliatifs et il faut surtout laisser
faire ça aussi c'est une consigne cette
fameuse convention citoyenne laissez-la
travailler alors il y a aussi un autre
paradoxe c'est Emmanuel Macron qui qui
dit je n'interviens pas je fais en
quelque sorte de votre silence et puis
il parle à son retour de Rome donc il
est il a rencontré le pape au Vatican il
parle en
souvent c'est de la communication
indirecte c'est un offre il discute avec
les journalistes alors c'est censé
rester confidentiel mais le président
s'est pertinemment que ces propos
sortiront dans la presse le lendemain et
puis partout et ça ne nous pas le
lendemain dans le Figaro par exemple on
apprend que le président avait confié
que le pape savait qu'il ne ferait pas
n'importe quoi alors on parlait de
religion tout à l'heure il y a
certainement un intérêt enfin en tout
cas un souci religieux du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on comprend
qu'il a donné des gages au pape François
et dans le journal La vie il y a
carrément des propos directs du
président qui sont rapportés où il
aurait dit la mort n'est pas un acte
technique finalement sans communication
directe vous le voyez on a appris
beaucoup de choses on a appris par
exemple que cette question de fin de vie
ne concernerait que les majeurs donc on
n'aurait pas le modèle belge c'était
référé au modèle beige pendant un moment
au printemps exit le modèle beige et
puis qu'il n'y aurait pas de référendum
et que rien serait décidé avant 2024
alors effectivement ça fait beaucoup de
d'informations distillées pour quelqu'un
qui ne voulait rester en dehors des
discussions pourquoi il a il agit comme
ça parce que sur cette question cruciale
Emmanuel Macron reste Jupiter et il veut
absolument pas que le débat tourne vous
savez rappelez-vous comme le mariage
pour tous c'est à dire que il ne veut
pas que la rue s'en empare il ne veut
pas que les Français s'en emparent ce
qui est aussi paradoxal puisque on
rappelle qu'il y aura une convention
citoyenne sur ce sujet mais il ménage
aussi et surtout sa majorité qui est
divisée sur le sujet sa famille à sa
propre famille politique mais aussi bien
sûr la droite qu'il soigne qu'il soigne
à cette droite politiquement c'est quand
même inquiétant je trouve parce que
finalement l'amiral manuel Macron ne
donne pas de cap lui-même hésite et
c'est lui qui va trancher une fine avant
même que la convention citoyenne ne
commence ses travaux sur ce sujet on
peut d'ores et déjà se poser la question
est-ce que ce sera vraiment le marqueur
et son second et dernier quinquennat ce
marqueur social ou juste une adaptation
de la loi claesh néonetti que lui-même
Emmanuel Macron juge inadapté et juste
qu'elle est floue pour certains cas je
peux dire quelque chose bien sûr
j'allais vous donner la parole vous êtes
gentil je crois que ce qui est dommage
et là je vous rejoins tout à fait c'est
que les parlementaires les
parlementaires le 8 avril 2021 ont voté
à 240 voix contre 24
un projet de loi donne-moi l'article
premier au cours d'une niche
parlementaire et cette première article
dit qu'ils acceptent l'aident actif à
mourir j'utilise pas le mot euthanasie
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
donc cet article a été fondamental sauf
que c'était une niche parlementaire et à
minuit il y avait 4000 amendements et
cette émie de côté mais ce qui est
dommage c'est que 296 parlementaires de
toute tendance ont été voir Jean Castex
en disant ce débat était insuffisant
c'est pas une niche parlementaire qu'il
nous faut il nous faut un vrai débat
commentaires et on lui a dit niet alors
je pense qu'il a dit net parce que il a
dû en parler au président de la
République et je pense que de se décider
le problème et de ne pas aller jusqu'au
référendum non plus donc
mélenchinement convention citoyenne et
vous ne l'avez dit et ensuite quand même
le Parlement qui a bien maman si la
convention citoyenne dit bah oui il faut
changer le clavier il faudra il faudra y
venir au Parlement donc cette enchères
et et la responsabilité donnée à des
citoyens français tirés au sort
représentatif qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ben je pense que ça recule le
problème moi je pense que ça va se
terminer au Parlement et c'est normal
j'aurais du Parlement que le Sénat va
jouer son rôle actuellement vous avez
quatre projets de loi qui ont été
déposés par des partis politiques
différents au Parlement vous avez un
projet de loi qui pour nous mon
association est l'idéal de votre
sénatrice madame de La Gontrie qui
bien qui est honnête qui précise les
choses de façon assez claire tout en
étant pas excessive et donc ce sont des
bases de discussion et laissons les
parlementaires agir c'est leur rôle
alors ce débat il questionne les
croyants et les religions on l'a vu tout
à l'heure et questionnent évidemment
aussi les les médecins des médecins qui
ont été apostro fait par Alain coq qui
était atteint d'une maladie incurable il
a fait deux grèves des soins grèves de
la fin en étant 2020 pour réclamer ce
droit à l'euthanasie il est mort deux
mois après cette interview il est allé
en Suisse pour un suicide assisté en
écoute
dans les failles depuis 50 ans
on leur enseigne que la mort est un
échec du médecin
c'est pas le cas
ça fait partie du cycle de la vie le
cycle de la vie n'est pas un échec
le rôle d'un médecin c'est d'accompagner
le patient dans ces pathologies de le
guérir quand il le peut et de soulager
quand il ne peut plus
parce qu'ils ont trouvé atroce ce que
semblait vivre leur proche décédé
pendant cette sédation profonde et
continue donc voyez le serment
d'Hippocrate là il est interprétable
entre guillemets parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'actuellement prolonge pas
l'agonie la mort la mort est un échec
nous dit à ce qu'effectivement les
médecins sont enfin et ça explique
peut-être les acharnements
thérapeutiques auxquels on peut assister
parfois est-ce que les médecins sont
logiques les médecins sont formés à
prolonger la ville et à soulager nos
souffrances le médecin enfin pour moi
pour mon éthique doit s'occuper de la
naissance à la mort c'est son rôle il
n'a pas démissionné au dernier moment
c'est son rôle d'accompagner le patient
et de répondre à la demande du patient
ce qui n'est pas dans le dans le sexe ce
n'est plus le serment d'Hippocrate c'est
le serment du Conseil de l'Ordre soyons
clairs c'est un mode d'Hippocrate l'été
il y a 400 ans après Hippocrate il a été
changé au moins quatre cinq fois moi ce
que je vais prononcé
en 68 n'a plus rien à voir j'exagère
par le Conseil d'ordre appelons les
choses telles qu'elles sont donc ça peut
changer dans le serment d'Hippocrate il
y avait je ne ferai pas d'avortement
vous le savez très bien que ça a disparu
donc c'est un texte qui change il faudra
le faire évoluer bon donc je pense que
moi je pense que le médecin doit le
faire raison monsieur il doit s'occuper
et répondre la demande du patient
jusqu'au bout et les médecins ne sont
pas formés à ça alors soyons clair c'est
pas dans la philosophie déontologie
médicale et c'est un vrai problème
plusieurs pays d'Europe qui autorisent
dès aujourd'hui le tanazie les Pays-Bas
la Belgique le Luxembourg
l'Espagne alors je voudrais quand même
il nous reste quelques minutes qu'on
parle de la marchandisation de la mort
Florence lassarade est-ce que est-ce que
c'est une dérive qu'il faut craindre si
on rentre voilà dans dans cette liste de
pays qui autorise l'euthanasie c'est un
des écueil
il y a des endroits où on propose un des
C4 étoiles il y a des c'est vrai il peut
si on pense à la Suisse par exemple
ça peut être un petit peu être
marchandisé moi je préfère je sais pas
si vous avez la réponse
dans ces pays-là en Suisse en Suisse
de l'origan l'origan aux États-Unis où
on laisse pendant 6 mois
le nécessaire à en gros a disparaître
et si au bout de six mois la personne
n'a pas utilisé
il rend le produit et s'il y a une
réévaluation savoir si on lui laisse
plus longtemps etc donc est-ce que c'est
pas est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi
en dehors des médecins responsabiliser
aussi la personne enfin ce qu'il faut
aider la personne à
évoluer sur le sujet ou pas d'ailleurs
j'en sais rien ça doit pas être un sujet
uniquement médical mais je pense que là
je vous rejoins il y a pas de formation
aux soins palliatifs dans les études
médicales il faut se spécialiser enfin
c'est pas
enseigner de psychologue ou pas
la crainte de la mort c'est l'angois
enfin il y a cette souffrance physique
mais il y a la souffrance la peur de
mourir aussi qui existe et où
l'acceptation l'acceptation ou pas quand
les soins s'arrêtent il y a un moment où
on bascule on dit bon bah c'est vrai il
y a plus rien à faire ben
on accepte et on donc on peut aller on
peut cheminer vers la mort mais tout ça
c'est
je sors un petit peu du sujet là c'est
non non mais de toute façon c'est
passionnant sur la marchandisation le si
on vote une loi en France alors
évidemment il y aura plus ce côté
insupportable d'être obligé d'aller à
l'étranger de devoir quitter son
environnement naturel enfin habituel
c'est pour mourir mais il y aura
peut-être aussi du business de la mort
en France alors je voudrais boire dire
que quand vous regardez l'Hexagone tous
les pays qui sont autour de l'hex ont
évolué on est le seul ne pas avoir
évolué y compris l'Allemagne y compris
l'Italie qui ont évolué l'Espagne le
Portugal l’autriche etc
en France on bouge pas très très vite
sur la marchandisation et ben si vous
voulez la Belgique ça fait 20 ans qu'ils
ont d'expérience il y a pas de
marchandisation je connais bien le
problème et le marchandisation en Suisse
parce que parce que voilà les Français
sont obligés d'y aller mais donc s'il
n'y a pas de Suisse il n'y aura pas de
marchandisation donc c'est pas c'est pas
séparer débitoire et c'est pas
obligatoire merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir merci à ce débat de Villa belge
rappelle le titre de votre livre le
médecin la liberté et la mort pour le
droit de choisir sa fin de vie chez
plongé terminé par un sourire parce que
j'espère que vous m'avez pas trop
entendu toussé mais ça doit être
psychosomatique on fait des patients
faire la fin de vie et je tousse comme
c'est pas permis pour la première fois
de la saison bref voilà merci à tous de
votre fidélité je vous dis à lundi merci
Laetitia d'avoir participé à cette
émission évidemment
désolé d'avoir oublié de vous présenter
en ouverture voilà l'invité de la
matinale de Public Sénat demain ce sera
Jean-François Colosimo qui est historien
des religions et éditeur il sera face à
Oriane Mancini belle fin de soirée à
toutes et à tous avec ou sans tout
caverneuse
[Musique]